[Music]
you know what they say guys patience is
a virtue the boy has no patience now
this is especially true when it comes to
csgo picture this guys you're lurking in
a corner when you start hearing some
sound cues the enemy team is so eager to
get to site they run right by you
without even noticing you're there every
fiber of your being is screaming at you
to pull the trigger now but you hold
your nerve for the big payoff that's
right guys this week on best of we're
talking about csgo pros holding that
nerve and exercising that trigger
discipline or at least trying to so
let's start things off with some
ice-cold trigger discipline place he's
called Kenny now he's gonna execute them
all pork yours free backs that the
barrels an interesting position here he
might have to go they've all passed them
out here we go this is gonna be
absolutely massive coming anybody can
taco but it might be enough to buses one
he wants the whole round this is so
greedy they could lose everything in
this round if this is to work out it's
looking we do one more kill there's the
one tire picks up another one oh my god
very close the u.s. teen hand
Seuss out instead and looking to get a
little bit closer and heritage mix walk
on take a pickup and get one more Chavez
can't even he comes right into a Tareq
with a huge double kill the knife we
want it he told us wish it on Tyler that
kid I really get him down nice could
actually mean a lot more than he think
she's not gonna go for it I can tell you
see basically
[Music]
play prepares you to go for the flank
snacks after shopping book down any bite
precision their mentor the good here
Buddhist bro such
but snacks is walking around
he what it
finish the job so now it comes down to a
to be three shots
he's just sitting underneath this guy
working his way and so slowly over that
patience pays off you can mine up good
even maybe two for one things didn't
take it either I could not take that as
that smoke dissipates he's gonna swap
hold his head sooner he gets off the
booze but he's still there he's trying
to line it up he wants to make sure it's
perfect the tables not always the most
accurate count of the game and he's got
trigger discipline to find one second
one's harder when they'll double begin
he does find an easy one for the win but
the thing is they don't he can shoot
them up right here not checking the
first one get right letting them through
the triple
leaving seized alone how as the mister
boombastic one might say is you gonna go
sing it's a comedy good for life because
it takes all these it to be ready all it
takes is a very very hard position to
move out of and they are doubled up and
do they check the corner that's a
question cabbie let's pause he finds us
first so much damage to refresh as well
the flashes over the top but yeah be
avoided he goes one step ahead north we
will have pistol round to find their
seventh he's always leaving it down to
golden magnificent play from golden to
save them in this round gets the fourth
as well is there one more for the book
yes there is another ace comes in the
second inning health time is about to
run out actually so Gotham and that's
why he's run away he's like yeah all of
a second mate wait wait wait I'll bait
you kill itself rez can't land it gets
taken down and rack and he's hurt as
well cat right this is gonna be nasty
does he look like
yes he does easiest shot of his life
noise alpha tonight shouldn't the deck
just waiting for the bomb to get a
dachshund
muscle : Otto these kind of your mind
obviously turnabout tunnel Peter scope
the video signal partly sunny payback
the kitchen or closer in the clock let's
see how long this poster will last
indicates we've taken up a happy is
playing the local role wait and get some
headshot this one they will head still
have no idea that's the way he's coming
from the bomb to be taken down that wall
happy just doing happy things there's a
third heads off for him this is my
father loves we know they just given SMG
instead of chasing biding his time
letting her till you can get more this
is gonna be so quickly there's one
there's two then I've been sick cover
three as well some ups are covering it
but in they go tarik has got his first
kill that's nothing that goes down
Stewie pushing and looking for a cow
react to put up a bullhorn though he's
pushed right past the nobody was he
watching it he's crawling behind them
however he's losing his teammate so he
needs to strike soon there's the first
one combo get into a second trying to
shut them down more how's the call here
because he should be able to catch off
the masala get the kill but then but
just will know he's there does he wait
oh this is huge
listen stimuli we'll see here with : at
this point nice holding back now good
trigger discipline Ozzie spot at the
fourth player in the meantime though
Davy finds that first kill
taco goes respond with his own pickup at
now cold strike stiff tapping snow
casually there now sometimes that
patience really pays off and leaves you
in the position to get that sweet sweet
$1,500 reward that's right guys this
next section is all about the knife
kills Romi hides in the toilets gets all
the information is you'll just be lying
in wait ready to try and push from the
rear device could actually go down
because of this you won't expect it
trigger discipline on the displays go
for the butcher plate he does up the
knife is you'll cut him up and make a
bit of a meter this one out of the
follow-up headshots not easy money
[Music]
let's shake it up speed it up the don't
give a [ __ ]
can they deal with their fix you up here
actually care I just pick up the opening
kill there on gmx oh that's really good
FX shows waiting timing is everything
he's gonna be jumping down does make
some noise but not enough Oh Sally only
gets one more kill but I might be enough
Oh is he gonna bring out the knife oh I
can't believe you've done this JW s
itself all three to close it down on the
hood it's even connected I'm gonna be
dead lamb from a Gila puts a break-in on
little system under the weather
oh we should you jump it out videos a
break today
dollar dollar bills y'all do you have
Kevlar behind snap you can get some aks
away from space soldiers but this is
looking a little bit ominous because
Gaede only has a USP he could get a free
kill up to Centaurus though he's weak
right I'll stay open no one's check the
big deal what is happening here but no
one checking the pit space soldiers come
on dudes
nitro rest in peace the question is
mac-10 bullet or night
will prevail for the money look guys
nobody bats a thousand
sometimes you've got all the info all
the patience and you're staring down the
easiest kill of your life then you whip
your spray the guy turns on you and you
hope nobody saw that Valley Falls and
now virtus Pro tell even the basic sound
working out tears you go on top of the
terrors play let's do it go for it as
long game just waiting for the smile
does near offices their shroud charge
Hacha gonna wait behind the server let's
go this is even better this is even
better ok but has to make the decision
this becomes a little awkward bisquits
is still waiting for this waiting
there's no reason to wait for anyone
else yeah the problem is when he goes
that way he's gonna fall off he actually
had to take that shot no oh god ok maybe
you're right
[Music]
best anomaly will be aware of his
position on one player coming up secret
see coming out of hell if he doesn't
shoot I live here but you have to worry
about the bomb they didn't hear him drop
he has two players lined up yeah I said
he had to worry about bomb he certainly
had to move a little bit awkward now
four attack two because they've got many
angles to watch how is he not that
killer that might favor him late if he
can get part of the heels of her and he
will fast enough he's gonna get another
one he's looking for a second he's not
sure he's realized he turned around and
that's gonna cost
which may cost them more Ukrainians two
of these shots that said 16 to five an
absolute battery and he's done it means
he's gonna be toying with him
if we come back now guys if this best-of
taught you anything it's that patience
is the key to success except when it
comes to hitting that subscribe button
which you should do right now see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]